a new poll out from quinnipiac which
tends to skew results strongly in favor
of democrats shows joe biden's approval
rating dropping to a new low of 37
meanwhile rasmussen which leans slightly
to the right has found that 58 percent
of voters are either not very or not at
all confident that biden is physically
and mentally up to the job of being
president and
only 38 percent of voters believe that
joe biden is actually making decisions
in the white house with a majority of
likely voters believing that others are
making decisions for him and while biden
blows it on the economy on foreign
policy on everything else in between
republican governors and senators are
looking to fill the vacuum and looking
to take his job in 2024 i'm michael
nolsas the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from moose chuckle who
says i hope chyna is as impressed with
our choice in military leadership as we
are with them flying a missile around
the world and us not knowing about it
yes i i suspect right now you're
alluding to
uh richard levine
now who goes by rachel levine who is our
nation's first female four-star admiral
who
is not a woman and who has never spent a
day of his life in the military but you
know it could almost equally apply to
our actual commanders in the field
woke general milly passing out critical
race theory and all the rest while we
are
parsing the white supremacist
intersectional hegemony uh china is
sending potential nuclear warheads
around the world and through low outer
space pretty
spooky stuff you know
when
these bring up matters of life and death
okay existential questions
which is why i think it's very important
to discuss 40 days for life you know a
couple of days ago the cdc made a very
accidental admission
they admitted that babies are babies
even before the babies are born
this was a big mistake for them because
the
cdc and the ruling class
do not oppose abortion okay
the pro-abortion movement is alive and
well in this country and they're
fighting back harder than ever because
there's a fair chance right now
that the supreme court could overturn
roe versus wade and planned parenthood v
casey you're gonna need to know the
arguments on how to fight back and to
defend life there's a great new book
from 40 days for life it's what to say
when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion it's already been a
number one amazon new release it's a
number two amazon bestseller it's on its
second printing
the book is super easy to use gives you
which arguments work which arguments
don't work that well and which have
convinced people on the fence abortion
supporters even planned parenthood
workers what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion how to
change minds and convert hearts in a
brave new world it's available now go to
amazon or get it directly from 40 days
for life at 40daysforlife.com
joe biden is really blowing it i am not
saying this to take a partisan shot or
because i i want to score one for the
republicans and smack down the democrats
or at least not just because of that
i'm just pointing out that on every
single
issue joe biden right now is failing the
only issue that he used to do pretty
well on was the coronavirus
that's why as afghanistan imploded as
the economy imploded he kept just trying
to bring everyone's attention back to
the coronavirus
even that now is not really looking good
for his numbers and the overall approval
rating at 37
is really really dismal
in the meantime younger more vibrant
more conservative people are looking to
take his job and they're looking to fill
that gap most notably
florida governor ron desantis who is
addressing the supply chain crisis this
is one of the most important economic
problems that we're facing right now he
is addressing the supply chain crisis by
opening up his ports in florida for the
benefit of the entire country
you see more empty shelves than than
we're used to seeing and there's
shortages of different things of course
we're also seeing increased cost in
terms of inflation uh year-over-year
increase in food prices so far is the
highest it's been in 10 years
and of course many commuters have been
have been suffering under about a 50
percent increase in gasoline and so you
see a lot of problems i know they just
announced while in california maybe
they'll start having the the port
operate 24 7 our ports operate 24 7. i
mean that should be happening anyways uh
and so we in florida uh have the ability
uh to help alleviate these log jams and
help to ameliorate the problems with the
supply chain and part of it is because
we've long been committed to reliable
modern and accessible port facilities
since i became governor in 2019 we've
allocated almost a billion dollars to
over 70 florida seaport projects and
these are
approaches that have made us really
really strong it made us really really
strong it's been really really good for
the country now look
i
think this is a good thing in and of
itself i think it shows strong
leadership i'm really glad he's doing it
i think it will benefit florida a lot
and it very likely will benefit the
entire country
all right i have a great deal of respect
for governor desantis i'm actually going
to see governor desantis this coming
weekend at the claremont institute's
annual gala they're giving him the
statesmanship award and i will be
emceeing that event
but beyond just what this means for
florida and the country
to me the most impressive thing here
with regard to ron desantis's clear
presidential ambitions is not even what
he's doing on the ports or what he's
doing on the lockdowns or what he's
doing on the virus or taxes or whatever
it's his incredible ability
to navigate the news cycles
no matter what is going on in the
country no matter what issue biden is
failing on
ron desantis is just right there
showing the alternative
this is a very impressive political
skill because
traditionally it's it's been considered
that
governors are in the best position to
run for president because they're in an
executive role
they can show leadership they can bring
people together they can show a
strong list of real accomplishments
whereas for congressmen or senators or
diplomats it's a little bit harder
because you're working more in teams
you're not really an executive in in
most cases and you're not really the one
who can who can show tangible results at
least not nearly as much as a governor
can but the problem with the governors
is that the issues are local
so yes you can say i did a great job for
my constituents here and i focus i did
really well on this florida issue but it
doesn't always play throughout the rest
of the country and what desantis has
done
i think uniquely among the governors
is he's got a good record of
accomplishment in florida
but they always seem to have national
implications
he even did it on the border so forget
about coronavirus and the ports for a
second even on the border he said
we are going to help secure the border
here we're going to send a floridians to
go secure the border why there's it's
not as though mexicans are flowing into
florida
i mean i suppose they are after a few
stops along the way
but he's he's doing a really good job
of putting himself in the national
conversation and so it's pretty clear
that he is hoping to be president that
might be complicated if donald trump
runs again in that case probably
desantis is the hardest hit because in a
way they're kind of running in the same
lane but for right now it's hard to see
how desantis could be doing a better job
positioning himself for 2024.
now he's not the only one who wants to
run in 2024 it would seem to me i don't
have any insider information here i'm
just observing politics that josh hawley
who is a senator who's also leading
leading the charge especially with
regard to big tech
he is
apparently positioning himself in 2024
as well and he just scored a pretty big
point too in this in this particular
case
on a judicial nominee so
there's a a judge a liberal judge holly
thomas who is now
serving in los angeles and biden is
nominating her to serve on the court of
appeals
holly thomas came out
and
stood by this idea that boys should be
allowed into the girl's bathroom and
said there's no risk whatsoever and no
threat posed to girls by sending boys
into the girls bathroom obviously
complicated by what just happened in
loudoun county the story that the daily
wire broke of a ninth grade girl being
raped in a bathroom where boys were
allowed to go in by a boy who sometimes
wore a dress really doesn't look good so
josh hawley
grills her on this very topic do you
judge still stand by your preposterous
claim
that there's no danger posed by boys in
the girls room
i have to ask you in light of what we
are seeing in loudoun county there are
reports about this in other places but
it's particularly troubling
in light of the recent events in loudoun
county
where a
boy in late may was sexually assaulted a
ninth grade girl in her school's
restroom after identifying as he
identified as being gender fluid he was
transferred
to another school
where a second assault occurred just
earlier this year
do you stand by your comments in these
briefs that there is there is no
evidence of
violence or crime in restrooms by
allowing biological males to use
biological females restrooms
thank you for the question senator
hawley
as i explained to senator grassley
in every case that i
had as an advocate
it was my duty to represent the views of
my
clients so
this answer goes on for several minutes
and holly keeps trying to get her to
answer the question and she continues to
stonewall and won't and won't answer it
she sticks to it holly's question is
pretty simple you put your name on this
document saying that there's absolutely
no threat by sending boys into the girls
room
and
he says do you still stand by that in
light of the
evidence that that isn't true and she
goes i
have to advocate for my clients and as a
judge i would not necessarily i'd be
advocating well okay but you it's not
just that you signed a statement saying
i'm advocating for my clients you signed
a statement saying this is true so do
you have no integrity are you a liar are
you stupid do you still believe this
what's the answer
and this woman she's a good politician
herself she just refuses to answer and
she keeps talking in this really boring
tone
and frankly she masks the radicalism of
her position in this really boring
procedural sort of
tone but what she's saying is
one yes there's no risk posed to girls
by sending men into the girls room
two i don't care even if there is i am
willing to lie strategically
to to accomplish my political goals and
three i'm not even going to give you the
satisfaction of admitting what i've just
implicitly
suggested to you one mistake holly makes
here i hate to nitpick but the mistake
holly makes
is he uses this phrase biological males
this has become popular among
conservatives they will say he is a
biological male
as though there's some other kind of
male as though you can he's not a
biological male but he's a spiritual
male he's a psychological male this it's
a really bad phrase i know people say it
sometimes they're just not even thinking
people should stop using that phrase it
grants the left's premise that there are
different kinds of i'm a biological male
but i'm a psychological female no
there's none of that there's boys and
girls guys okay and when we use this
squishy language we think we're being
really clever and we think we're being
really scientific actually we're just
being squishes and we're we're giving
and conceding this premise that they're
they're different shades of male and
female and really we're granting the
premise that gender is sort of fluid and
socially constructed makes you want to
just protect the very basic elements of
your life
which is why i would recommend you check
out lifelock did you know that october
is cyber security awareness month i
actually did not know that because i i
like to think that every month is cyber
security awareness month because i don't
want people stealing my information okay
this year's theme is do your part be
cyber smart getting cybersmart starts
with cyber hygiene that includes strong
passwords setting up multi-factor
authentication on your accounts
and regularly updating software on your
devices
it's very important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats for instance your
social security number for sale on the
dark web if they detect your information
lifelock will send you an alert no one
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock identity theft protection
join right now save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com
knowles kennedy wlas that is
lifelock.com
slash knowles k-n-w-l-e-s for 25
off
speaking of women
a wnba team has won the championship
what is the wnba team i don't really
know there was a championship apparently
i did you watch it no you didn't not a
single person listening to this show
right now watched the wnba championship
or probably even knew that it was going
on
i don't think anyone did in the country
maybe some of the basketball players
themselves knew but i'm not even
convinced of that so one of the teams
won because i guess one of the teams has
to win and they hold a championship
parade
in chicago
the the championship parade i forget if
i print it out no unfortunately i didn't
there was a headline it said chicago
turns out for the wnba championship
parade and there's big buses here and
double deckers and people standing on
top waving to the adoring fans except
there was nobody there in the streets to
greet them
so you can see there's multiple buses
whole stream
you can hear the sirens behind them
and
now you just hear
it's so sad
it's so sad you hear so the streets are
are empty i mean there are a couple
people like bicycling alongside them
there are a bunch of cops
trailing them giving them a bit of a
motorcade but there's
almost not a single person out in the
street for the parade because no one
cares because it's the wnba and no one
even knew it was on
th this is sad this is sadder than not
having a parade
okay i'm not i don't begrudge the ladies
their
victory i don't i'm not interested in it
i don't
you know there are a lot of sports i
don't watch the curling championships
okay i don't watch
the
you know international shuffleboard
world series right i don't either just i
don't pay attention to a lot of these
things and certainly not to the wnba
but
what's so sad here
is broader than just the wnba it's the
problem with
pride culture it's the problem with the
i'm awesome kind of culture
i saw
oh this was so sad i saw someone that i
went to school with i was just scrolling
through instagram and i saw she posted
this picture
and and underneath she wrote i'm so
proud of this person i love this person
so much this person's doing such a great
job and i'm really proud of her
and it was a photo of herself
it was a f and i thought this is really
sad
but it's a common occurrence these days
you it's the self-love self-care
kind of culture where you you basically
just worship the self and the fact is if
you have to say it you probably don't
think it
right this is
i mean now we have whole months for
pride and for celebrating one's self
but
this is
quite the opposite of the traditional
understanding in our christian
civilization which is rather than saying
i'm awesome i'm the best i'm perfect
just the way i am we say i'm a miserable
sinner please have mercy on me i'm
broken i'm i've failed i i have sinned
in my thoughts and in my words and what
i have done and what i've failed to do
through my fault through my fault
through my most grievous fault that
that's the traditional understanding and
ironically or perhaps unexpectedly
that view of yourself will make you feel
much better about yourself and about the
world one because it's true we are all
broken the imagination of man's heart is
evil from the beginning the things we
want to do we don't do and the things we
don't want to do we do we are sinful and
we are in need of salvation
but two there is salvation we actually
can find it but we're not going to find
it in ourselves all right we're not
going to perfect ourselves of purely of
our own work it's just not going to
happen
the the
pride culture i think ultimately is is
just masking
a deep sorrow and a deep sort of despair
because if you are going to rely on
yourself to perfect your own life or to
perfect the world you are going to be
extremely
disappointed
would have been much better and and much
more attractive if these women had said
you know okay we played this game but no
one cares that's fine but maybe you keep
watching we did it for ourselves we did
it for the excellence of the sport
humility is much more attractive than
pride this is something we used to know
now we somehow have forgotten that pride
goes before destruction and a haughty
spirit before a fall speaking of women
in the workplace
nicole hannah jones
was just invited and then disinvited
from a school for a speaking event
and i suspect a lot of conservatives are
going to get this issue
wrong
this issue is almost a set up for
conservatives because conservatives in
recent years
have complained about cancel culture and
complain about censorship
and
specifically complained about this at
schools and for lecture opportunities
right
so
this story is just going to expose
conservatives as hypocrites right if we
don't think that nicole hannah jones who
created the fictional 1619 project
who lied about american history
who is uh
really an
unfortunate character on the american
pseudo-academic scene if we don't
think that she should lecture
well then we're hypocrites on free
speech and canceled culture aren't we no
i don't think so
but we do need to correct some of our
language the whole point of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds was to
correct the way we're talking about free
speech because these issues of wokism
and political correctness they're not
just a battle between free speech and
censorship
it's not just the procedural formal
aspect of whether or not someone can
speak or not there's the substantive
aspect which is what are they saying
okay
first of all nicole hannah jones was
invited to the middle sex school
in concord this is not a college this is
not a graduate program this is a high
school and there's a big difference
between high schools and colleges
colleges have to to some degree in
universities have to some degree the
idea of a free marketplace of ideas the
idea that unconventional
lectures may be tolerated and may be
beneficial
high schools and certainly middle
schools and certainly elementary schools
are not quite that the purpose of those
places is to give you the basics so that
you can begin to think in this higher
way so i think
it is certainly appropriate at the high
school level to cancel this fabulous
from speaking and and very possibly at
the college level
as well
okay there are different
types of speakers here and different
types of speeches and we have to also i
think rethink the purpose of college
education university education
moving beyond even the high school and
nicole hendon jones thing for a second
is the purpose of going to a university
to just hear a bunch of random different
views and the weirder the view the
better and the and the more weird views
you hear the smarter you're going to be
or
is the purpose of a college education
to learn correct things to learn true
things
to to
steep yourself in the good the true and
the beautiful to be not merely critical
in your thinking but constructive in
your thinking and actually build up a
proper education and control your base
passions and see the world in a way that
is more or less
accurate
more accurate than when you went in i
have clearly set up the question in such
a way that i'm showing you i think it's
the latter i don't i don't think that
just anybody should be allowed to speak
at a university nobody does do you
really do you really think that some
neo-nazi should be able to speak at a
university
maybe you do maybe there are some
free speech extremists who say i
absolutely believe that a neo-nazi
should speak at university okay do you
think that i don't know
a serial killer do you think a deranged
lunatic serial killer
should be permitted to speak at a
university
pro no you don't right i don't think
that you do why because you would say
that a student would not benefit from
hearing the the ravings of some deranged
lunatic serial killer right
but
but isn't that cancel culture isn't that
censorship students benefit from hearing
all sorts of kooky ideas no they benefit
from hearing true things and and
i'm not calling nicole hannah jones a
deranged lunatic serial killer okay but
i am pointing out that like a deranged
lunatic serial killer nicole hannah
jones doesn't really have anything
valuable to say because the only thing
that nicole hannah jones is known for is
a lie it's a thesis that the american
revolution was fought to preserve
slavery there is no evidence for that
there is a lot of evidence to the
contrary actual academic historians shot
down this thesis including the academic
historians who are on the far left who
actually are great very sympathetic to
nicole hannah jones
so the only thing that's going to come
out of this woman speaking at a
university is filling students heads
with lies
and i think we need to regain on the
right the spinal fortitude to say
no we don't think that the purpose of
university education is to fill kids
heads with lies right they're getting
enough of that already on gender theory
and these crazy racial theories wait
until you hear what's going on
out of mit
that's not that's not the purpose of an
education we i think we need to move
beyond
a a fun line but it's a little bit of a
shallow line we've said in certain uh
years recent years that
we we just need more and more speech at
universities and no one should ever be
canceled and everyone should be
permitted to speak and
oh colombia is going to invite iranian
president mahmoud ahmadinejad yeah great
that's awesome terrific more speech the
better no
we need to be discerning we need to
recognize we have judgment we have moral
conscience we have faculties of reason
we can tell the difference between true
and false and right and wrong and we're
going to stand
by that we're going to stand on the side
of true and good and against wrong and
false and evil
then today is going to be talking about
how dave chappelle
is funny
he's funny and you got to deal with that
and that's too bad go check that out
also
you can subscribe and start listening to
morning wire on apple spotify wherever
you listen to podcasts you can leave a
five-star review if you like what you
hear we will be right back with a lot
more
speaking of cancel culture
at mit a movement is underway to cancel
a lecturer
here's the background
mit invited a professor
to lecture
this professor his name is dorian abbott
he's a scientist
he has criticized affirmative action
i have criticized affirmative action you
have criticized affirmative action
everybody with two brain cells to rub
together has criticized affirmative
action which gives black people and
hispanic people an advantage in
university admissions and employment and
disadvantages white people and asian
people so anyone who thinks we ought to
treat people fairly regardless of their
race would criticize affirmative action
as this guy did and now he's being
criticized for it
and and uh people are demanding that he
no longer lecture so i'm going to focus
in this is from the new york times i'm
going to focus in
on one professor who is not even at mit
she's at williams college
uh this this professor is very upset
that uh that professor abbott was
invited to lecture
her name is phoebe a cohen she's a
geosciences professor and department
chair at williams
and
and she doesn't want this guy to lecture
at mit she doesn't want anyone who's
ever criticized affirmative action to be
able to speak at a college campus
now the new york times to their credit
when interviewing this this cancel
culture professor
said well hold on don't you think that
the the cure
for this guy's bad ideas would just be
to debate him you know come on professor
phoebe why don't you just debate him or
you know have people present an
alternative point of view
and phoebe cohen
the williams professor said no she said
quote
this idea of intellectual debate and
rigor as the pinnacle of intellectualism
comes from a world in which white men
dominated
so uh
this is not the own
that she thinks it is because what she's
saying is um
intellectual debate and rigor
unfairly advantage white guys
that if you have a system that is based
on intellect
and debate and logic and rigor
white guys will have an unfair advantage
because they are much
better at intellectual argumentation and
they are more able better able to deal
with rigorous debate than women and
black people and asians i guess and
hispanic and just anybody else okay
david duke all right whoa come down
there richard spencer
this this lady is just saying that white
white guys are smart and and competent
and logical and all the other people are
just big dummies and so they can't do it
and so because they can't keep up in a
debate we've got to just silence the
white guys before they can get their
point of view out
sounds pretty racist to me or sexist or
whatever ism
word you want to use
but this is i think a popular view
on
on the left but it's worth it's worth
taking them at their at their word that
this is really what they believe okay
because
we have two
two options here choose which way you
want to go western civilization you can
either
go down the r road of intellectual
debate and rigor and proving that some
things are good and true and beautiful
and arguing against things that are ugly
and false and and hideous
and wrong
or
you can take reason and logic out of our
politics
and then we become
grunting bands of baboons clubbing each
other over the head right that's it when
aristotle says man is the political
animal when aristotle says that the
thing that that
distinguishes man from the beasts is
that we have speech right and we can
actually reason with one another and
persuade one another he's distinguishing
us from animals in this regard we will
either have civilization and speech and
debate and rigor
or we will be animals clubbing each
other over the head and whoever has the
stronger interest will win
that's really what this has come down to
and it does remind us that we do need
limits here okay this is why we have a
political system this is why we have
limits imposed by our constitution by
our political tradition
because we don't want to live like that
okay we do not want to live in the world
of phoebe cohen
we want to live in a civilized world of
intellectual debate and rigor which i
think
is not only limited to white guys i i
bet
non
non-white guys non-men uh non-white
people i think actually they can they
can deal with it too
speaking of the new york times
the new york times i just want to give
you a beautifully clear example of the
fake news coming out of the new york
times they have this podcast the day the
daily
it's hosted by michael bubba
welcome and it's the whole the whole
point of the daily is to get a lot of
radical leftism
into a really soft spoken kind of
moderate sounding podcast welcome to the
new york times the daily uh my name is
markup
and today the republicans are bad and
the democrats are good and i'm ba ba ba
ba and goodbye this is and so here's
just a flat out lie that was in the
episode title of the new york times the
daily quote how a single senator
derailed biden's climate plan wow oh my
goodness a single senator did that
gosh i didn't even know in the senate
that a single senator i guess the way
that a single senator could have
derailed a plan would be through
the filibuster right and maybe he just
filibustered for so many hours and hours
and hours that biden did he just give up
on it no usually the way the filibuster
works is the guy who's speaking ad
nauseum eventually he stops and then
they kind of move on so is that what
happened no okay let me see what what
exactly happened here because i see a
headline in the new york times paper it
says biden's climate plan stymied by one
sender so what hm
what happened
uh oh joe manchin okay joe manchin is
the senator and he he stopped it how did
he stop it though i it doesn't even
really say
is it there was only one go oh no wait
wait a second it's not no it's joe
manchin and all the republicans
so it wasn't just one senator who
stymied the plan it was um
51 senators
stymied the plan
that's oh that's the majority of
senators
so let me i'm just going to rewrite
those headlines
from from the new york times and the
daily
um
majority of senators stop biden's
climate plan but that doesn't sound as
good
right that sounds like government is
operating as it should which is the
people go out and they elect their
senators and then
depending on the votes that each side
has
you either move ahead with legislation
or against it
and most senators
representing most people
here opposed
the plan
but the new york times can't tolerate
that so they simply
lie
it's a it's a little subtle thing
because yes mansion is playing a role
here he's a democrat but he's a moderate
democrat he's not a radical left
democrat so he's he is playing this
decisive role
but the way the new york times talks
about it it's as if only democrats
matter in the senate it's only democrats
right the republicans they're not even
really legitimate there are there are
insurrectionists they're a threat to our
democracy the re all that really matters
is the democrats well
despite the whining of the new york
times uh mansion seems to be holding
relatively firm
beyond the climate plan
uh which is clear enough right joe
manchin represents a coal state
so if you have a big climate plan that's
going to get rid of coal joe manchin
can't possibly vote for that that would
be a betrayal of his constituents but
joe biden is broadly going to have to
pull back on his spending plan
you you know in this three and a half
trillion dollar budget joe biden put in
a ton of radical stuff
now it is being reported he might have
to cut back on
tuition-free community college
a path to permanent legal status for
illegal aliens
the
clean energy plan is part of this
uh however
[Music]
they they might try to keep in paid
family leave child tax credits and free
preschool although they might scale that
back as well so this is
this is overall
a win a relative win given that the
democrats have basically unified
government right now they have the house
they have the senate and they have the
white house
the fact that we can get rid of some of
the worst aspects of this budget is a
win and
it's important to look at this because
it's easy to believe these days
that the oligarchy the ruling class
which increasingly looks not really like
our democracy but looks like their
oligarchy it's not omnipotent it can't
just do whatever it wants to do we
sometimes think between the deep state
and the fouchies and the dems and the
libs they just do whatever they want big
tech and the media they can do whatever
they want and we have no say whatsoever
well no we do still have a little bit of
a say okay
they seem really really powerful and
they make themselves appear
more powerful than they are
but actually we still have a fair bit of
power here and and if we exercise it i
think we do still have a fighting chance
you're seeing this
especially throughout corporate america
in-n-out burger
in-n-out burger from my former state of
california
is standing up against big government
so the government there is trying to
mandate
that customers in order to go buy their
cheeseburger
need to have the fauci algae
and plenty of people don't want the
fauci algae and for good reason
they might object to the fact that it's
made with
in development and in some cases
production with fetal stem cells they
might not like the fact that people have
died from the vaccine including from
blood clots that's why they pause the
johnson johnson vaccine that people have
contracted nerve damage that people have
contracted myocarditis and pericarditis
one study out of uc davis
said that young men certain young men
might face greater risk from the from
the vaccine than from the virus itself
there are plenty of reasons
not to get the vaccine and so in and out
says we are this is a great line
we refuse
to become the vaccination police for any
government we fiercely disagree with any
government dictate that forces a private
company to discriminate against
customers who choose to patronize their
business this is a clear government
overreach they believe it is quote
unreasonable invasive and unsafe to
force our restaurant associates to
segregate customers into those who may
be served and those who may not whether
based on the documentation they carry or
any other reason
damn right
damn right baby i love it this is good
stuff
all right and it's you're not just
seeing it with in and out you're seeing
it also
at the the level of
corporations dealing with their
employees so it's not just dealing with
the customers but it's dealing with the
employees too southwest airlines
had major
flight delays they pretended it was
because of the weather but it was
obviously because of an employee walk
out or sick out well they're walking
back their vaccine mandate as well
southwest airlines will not place
unvaccinated staff on unpaid leave
while they await exemptions to the covet
19 vaccine so
initially southwest said that if the
the
airline employees are not vaccinated by
december 8 they're going to be cut off
from their pay they're going to be
placed on unpaid leave and now what
they're saying is quote this is a change
from what was previously communicated
initially we communicated that these
employees would be put on unpaid leave
and that is no longer the case so it's a
tail between their legs they're
admitting they're not going to do this
anymore
good stuff really good stuff
why do i like this so much
one of the reasons i like this so much
is not because as some libertarians are
saying you know my body my choice i
don't i don't believe my body my choice
i don't think it's true with abortion i
actually don't even think it's true with
vaccinations generally there are
mandated vaccines in american history
the supreme court has upheld the
legitimacy of this george washington did
it to the continental army and i
actually don't think you own your own
body i'm not a libertarian or a
libertine i don't think i chose to come
into this world i hope i don't choose to
come out of this world and i think i
have responsibilities
and and duties to my community and to my
god and i can't just do whatever i want
with my own body so i'm not a lib
in this regard but i want to get into
the specifics here of this vaccine the
way joe biden instituted this vaccine
mandate which he had initially admitted
he didn't really have the authority to
do
was he went around this roundabout way
and he said i'm not mandating it exactly
but i am saying that
the occupational safety and health
administration needs to mandate that
certain companies with more than 100
employees needs to mandate that the
businesses enforce the mandate
and if they don't we're going to try to
bankrupt them with fines
i think joe biden knows this is almost
certainly going to be struck down in
court that he doesn't really have the
authority to do this and he's just
hoping he can pressure everyone to get
the fouchy algae before the courts
realize that this is not legal
so okay
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
if joe biden is going to play this silly
cynical game i think the company should
too and i think the people should and i
think the employees and i think the
customers should pressure the companies
who are unfortunately squeezed in the
middle here to pressure the government
not to do this sort of thing what is
good
for the goose is good for the gander the
people and the employees still have a
lot of power especially amid our current
contrived labor shortage
the ruling class is not happy that
people are pushing back against these
mandates they're not they don't like
that they don't like it when people tell
them no
and you're seeing this especially in
crooked machine political towns such as
chicago so lori lightfoot who is as
close to a mobster as any
any
mayor currently in office
lori lightfoot is mandating that the
cops all take the fouchyache in chicago
chicago is basically a third world
country the the rates of violent crime
in chicago are through the roof and
so lori lightfoot
is demanding that cops
stay on the job but they've got to take
the fouchy at you so some cops are
saying no you know i think i'm going to
quit if you're going to make me take the
fouchiacci i think i'm just not gonna do
it i was just in chicago i was briefly
at o'hare airport i spoke to some cops
there and they were saying they're
looking at 40 to 50 percent
of cops just quitting or retiring early
or just leaving the job because they
don't want to deal with this
so what does lori lightfoot say is this
people exercising their freedom of
choice is this people
you know just exercising their moral
conscience and doing the responsible
thing no
no she calls it an insurrection
we believe that the fop leadership is
trying to foment in a legal work stop it
to shrink pure and simple we've laid
that out in the materials um and we're
not just we're not having that the
contract is clear and it's been known
for a long time uh the police unions are
not authorized to strike it's in their
collective bargaining agreement it's a
matter of state law what we've seen from
the fraternal order of police and
particularly the leadership is a lot of
misinformation a lot of half truths and
frankly flat out lies in order to induce
an insurrection and we're not having
that it's an insurrection right right i
forgot it's an insurrection
anything the democrats don't like is an
insurrection
anything they do like is a wonderful
defense of our democracy
so when for instance uh radical leftists
at the encouragement of democrat
politicians up to and including kamala
harris and staffers for joe biden when
they
you know set
courthouses on fire and attack police
buildings and kill dozens of people and
steal a bunch of sneakers during the blm
rides of 2020. that's a defense of our
democracy
kamala harris will bail them out of jail
because of how much they're defending
our democracy but when the horn guy
dances in the capital that's an
insurrection
when
leftists torch chicago and loot and
steal and kill and pillage and burn
that's a defense of our democracy that's
a wonderful thing when cops
don't want to inject themselves with an
experimental drug and so they very
peaceably just decide to retire that's
an insurrection the democrats are going
to do they already are doing to the word
insurrection
what they did to the word racist the
word racist doesn't mean anything
anymore it may once have meant something
it no longer does
if i think of the word racist i
i guess what i
think of is that you hate someone on the
basis of their race
that's what i would say
it's not i don't think it's just that
you
have preconceptions or judgments of
people on the basis of race everybody
does that hey think of an italian guy
think of an italian guy right now what
are you thinking of you're thinking of a
guy with a mustache who says hey it's
samia and you're thinking of pizza and
you're thinking of a loud argument with
his family at christmas and you think i
don't know you're thinking of you have
certain ideas hey think of an irishman
you're going to have some preconceptions
of what an irishman is you're probably
picturing a little leprechaun right now
with a pint of guinness or something and
saying hey they all be after me lucky
charms right that's that would be a
preconception but i don't think that's
racist
hey picture a chinese guy
what you're going to pick at least you
are picturing what he looks like was
that a is that a prejudgment a prejudice
a preconception well sure i don't think
it's racist
if you say i hate black people i guess
that i guess that that would be racist
right or i hate
the irish or something like that i hate
white people that certainly is racist
but the left tells us that's not racist
and now we're told
that anytime you say anything
positive or negative or neutral about a
protected
group
you are a racist
and anytime you say anything vicious or
hateful about a non-protected group
like
white people are asian people that's
you're totally that's totally fine
that's not a big deal
so the word doesn't mean anything an
insurrection right now i don't think
means anything
if blm defends our democracy and the
horn guy is an insurrectionist then ins
if cops just not taking an experimental
drug as an insurrection
then insurrection doesn't mean anything
anymore and it means you really ought to
reconsider
some of what you thought about january
6th
january's the great the worst attack in
american history
wasn't the senate building like
bombed
in within the last five decades i seem
to recall that i remember reading that
there have been multiple attacks
actually in the last century
that led to a lot of destruction
on
very furious senate and house buildings
but january's the horn guy
the podium they took pelosi's lectern
okay that's not good
it's not good to steal somebody's
lectern it's not good to steal
sneakers it's not good to steal gucci
handbags it's not good to torch the
country coast to coast but so one of
them is our democracy though and it's
really good in the other
is an insurrection i don't think so i
don't think so speaking of actual
insurrections
and coup d'etat
christopher steele you remember him
he was the tool who
who gave the democrats an excuse to spy
on the trump campaign by cooking up a
completely bogus report about how donald
trump was urinated on by hookers in
moscow
so
christopher steele just went on george
stephanopoulos's show on abc george
stephanopoulos a former communications
director for bill clinton right a
democrat uh propagandist
and steele defended his dossier and
stephanopoulos
gave some pushback he said no but come
on some things were false right can we
give at least the appearance of some
pushback and steel goes no
it was credible reporting we knew some
of it was right we suspected some of it
may never be provable but i've got a
great track record and the idea that i
would fabricate this document or
information is absolutely anathema i
wouldn't be a successful businessman if
that were my practice
and he's hoping that you don't pay
attention here because of course he
would be his his job was not to provide
true information or true opposition
research into donald trump his job was
to use his credential he's a lifelong
spook to use his credential to give
democrats a justification to spy on the
trump campaign and he did his job very
very well and it was a bs report but he
did it and the ruling class spied on the
trump campaign and by some fluke he
actually managed
trump actually managed to win
but the the ruling class remains
unrepentant
they do not care and we've got to stop
falling for their traps
whether it's on the january 6 or the
isms or the this or that or listen to
fouchy one more time or defe we got to
just tune that stuff out okay i think we
still have the chance to fight back and
rebuild our country but we've got to get
serious and start doing it ourselves
we've got to start winning elections and
using political power i'm michael
knowles is the michael see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show netflix
employees walk out to protest dave
chappelle's special and the media gush
over them plus the biden administration
says they've got vaccines for your
five-year-old but your kid will still
need to mask that's today on the bench
bureau shall give it a listen